en este pueblo remoto en el occidente de
afganistán se lleva a cabo una
distribución de comida organizada por
las naciones unidas en la entrada unas
mujeres que no están registradas tratan
de conseguir algo para mi marido
contrajo una deuda grande y nos abandonó
a donde se fue no sé
tiene un guardián masculino no no tengo
por ahora no podemos ayudarla solo las
personas que han sido registradas por
las autoridades locales pueden entrar al
recinto
no tengo nada si no recibo esta ayuda
tendré que mendigar
la mayoría de los habitantes en este
distrito son agricultores de pequeña
escala afectados por los episodios
constantes de sequía severa
este es un super cereal
es para mujeres embarazadas o para las
que acaban de dar a luz y están
amamantando
hubo una guerra un cambio de régimen
político una sequía todos estos
problemas llegaron juntos
esta ayuda es una segunda oportunidad
para las personas pero reducimos la
cantidad de beneficiarios a cuatro mil
251 personas es una disminución del 40%
y la onu tiene que reducir el número de
beneficiarios de estas distribuciones
para finales de junio principalmente por
falta de fondos
tomaremos su tarjeta de registro y a
quienes no se les devuelva su tarjeta
hoy no recibirán una ayuda de la próxima
vez
perdí la pierna por la explosión de una
mina y ahora tengo esta prótesis estoy
discapacitado que debería hacer a unos
kilómetros de distancia en este
campamento para desplazados internos la
ayuda internacional dejó de llegar desde
que el talibán tomó el poder el
representante de la comunidad quiere
mostrarnos la desesperación de los
habitantes no hay suficiente comida los
niños están cada vez más débiles
ella tiene 7 años y ella 5
ella se ve más pequeña porque está
desnutrida calentar
la manzanilla
y ya está
que la paz esté con ustedes como están
gracias todo está bien cómo está su
situación dónde está su marido se fue a
trabajar
no tenemos nada así que se fue a recoger
plantas para encender un fuego y hacer
té porque tenemos hambre
no nada más solamente comemos pan y agua
y sólo por la noche
cuando no tenemos nada tomamos agua a
veces nos tomamos una taza de té
no tenemos dinero para comprar comida
la mayoría de las familias aquí come pan
duro remojado en agua según la onu más
de un millón de niños afganos menores de
5 años están en peligro de desnutrición
en la provincia de herat su única
alternativa es este hospital dirigido
por médicos sin fronteras
esta es una de las salas de cuidados
intensivos en nuestro pabellón de
nutrición las posibilidades de
supervivencia de estos pacientes son muy
bajas si no reciben atención médica
todos los bebés que hay aquí sufren de
retraso en el crecimiento
el año pasado uno de mis niños me dio
sólo tenía un mes
no sé qué le pasaba
ese año la sequía y nos fue muy mal
económicamente
ahora lo mismo le está pasando a mi edad
esos meses ahora con frecuencia las
madres de estos bebés también están
desnutridas la situación en afganistán
es preocupante hay más casos de
desnutrición ahora que en años
anteriores no solo en edad sino también
en otras provincias lo que nos preocupa
en este momento no es sólo la
desnutrición de los niños sino también
la de las mujeres embarazadas mil
hembras están sumidas en la miseria sin
esperanza de tener un mejor futuro las
familias recurren a métodos desesperados
el padre de esta niña de 9 años la
vendió a un hombre de 49 sin la
aprobación de su madre por ahora la niña
todavía vive con su madre que está
tratando de devolverle el dinero al
hombre podemos morirnos de hambre pero
nunca venderé mi hija aquí está la
prueba he pagado 19.000 afganis de los
100.000 que mi marido recibió tengo
mucho miedo porque si no le pagó el
resto de enero se llevará a mi hija
[Música]
mi padre me vendió porque necesitaba el
dinero no teníamos nada que comer me
vendió porque tuvo que hacerlo aunque mi
madre trató de detenerlo
y nadie nos puede ayudar no tengo
trabajo y tengo tantas deudas no sé qué
hacer no sé cómo solucionarlo
cicc arte
en afganistán 23 millones de personas
sufren de hambre extrema una cifra que
corresponde a más de la mitad de la
población del país